this is a movie that has a tassets
emotional and dramatic center a trial
and yet in the earliest iterations of
this movie there was no trial explain
how that came in at what that says about
the story you are trying to tell to
Susan and Robert there wasn't a trial
because I think in the early iterations
we were trying to avoid the courtroom
taking over the movie and they didn't
know how to get into it without it
becoming a big presence but eventually
it felt like the dramatic intent of what
the potential of the story was going to
be needed to end with the Opera the
opportunity suddenly occurred one day
that oh well you have the opportunity
for a son to question his father on the
stand with him having sworn an oath not
to lie and he had basically gets him
pinned down to tell the truth about what
happened in the past which he can't get
those answers out of him any other way
so that climax was what really drove the
objective of like that trial coming into
the movie when I read it and I kind of
understood what he was going for even
though it was a very early draft and I
knew the kind of movie he wanted to make
and we really clicked on that I talked
to Robert about it and as he says he
kind of threw us a bone and like hung
out for a bunch of sessions during
development I mean you got to let him
get a limb do something so I you know he
but he became engaged we we had low
pressure on this one it kind of flew
under the radar and we got to no start
date no massive this effects budget
exactly no release date already all that
kind of stuff that were sort of used to
so but it was really argued I just like
films that have kind of an epic arc to
them you know and this felt to me even
though it's grounded in small-town
America and all the stuff this feels
dude this feels like an odyssey to me
and and then I read the script and there
was no way I was going to let anyone
else do it
once I was on board it's a job I'm an
actor I come in and on a daily basis you
you try to make the best and most
sincere and truthful journey from Inc to
behavior
and not keep it just an idea but make it
an ink to behavior not here but here and
it was a wonderful experience a
wonderful script terrific people to work
with and you know I guess maybe I was
blessed more than they were blessed I
don't know I mean every day we would you
know we come to set and be like you know
so what are we shooting today
oh we're just shooting the first time
you guys see each other in 20 years no
all right all right I get it and then
what are we doing tomorrow
we're shooting your first argument where
he knows that you're getting a divorce
all right next week eases up doesn't it
yeah well next week you're picking him
up from you know he's going and being
booked and and then we'll do the and
then we'll do bathroom scene and we just
be like all right and then this guy does
remember then we like have a drink they
go yeah we're gonna do that right before
we go to the court and I was just like
oh my god it was just this relentless
kind of mortifying one kind of hurdle
after another I'd watch what Bobby does
and I'd be like all right he didn't do
anything I have to go look at this and I
look at it and then the way it
translates once you're looking at
playback on a camera is there some
people who without having tricks they
just understand the simplicity and and
just just how to how to do it you know
and so I was honestly I was just trying
to follow his lead and not mess up half
the scenes we were in and then we went
to toe to toe to toe once in a while and
I was just hoping it wasn't actually mad
at me David I want to rewind the clock a
little bit and talk about the personal
experience in your life that inform this
story and how you thought about that as
you were making the film yeah I lost my
mother in 2007 and at the time before
before she passed when she first got ill
and I had a very contentious
relationship with her we didn't get
along very well for a lot of my life and
all this and my father had already
passed and I had this experience of like
oh my god I'm gonna be stuck in and I'm
the kid in life and pie and I'm stuck
with the tiger in the boat and it just
was this real and this realization that
I was
have to parent my parent and I didn't I
wasn't prepared for that I don't know
why that intellectually had occurred to
me but I never imagined that was gonna
happen as soon as it did and when I came
out of that experience and there are
some things in the movie that are on
screen that I went through and the week
after I started to write this story or
it started to form about this family
where a mother dies and the the buffer
between all the pressure and the family
is gone and this collision begins these
icebergs that are inevitably going to
slam into each other
and that I mean that was the impetus for
the for the original story could you
describe the scene in the bathroom it's
an incredibly beautiful scene very
moving very difficult I think as a SNES
an audience member to watch how did you
go about approaching that scene and what
did you want it how did you want it to
work
I just wanted it to be honest and
authentic and the approach towards
filming it was you know we spoke about
it very briefly we really all kind of
had instincts towards what it should be
and we went into it I knew it was
something that had to be done before
lunch and it just you know there was no
coming back from lunch to that scene and
so you know and that bathroom was you
not to ruin all the magic but it was
designed with the walls to be pulled and
flown and everything when lit flat and
kind of gruesome and and real and it was
three cameras three setups and it was
broken into three pieces and we shot it
in just a couple hours and it was just
about capturing an authentic moment of
performance between these two and I
don't think we a knew exactly what was
going to happen until it really happened
and it was just you know it was a
magical moment this movie has a lot to
say about family and about you know what
happens when somebody from your family
is gone and I'm curious Robert what do
you hope people take away from this
movie about what it has to say about
family
I don't know just that nothing nothing
works out the way you idealize it to and
that you have to you know you have to
deal with the kind of uncertainty of
things but then there's always your own
your own processes what's at the
forefront of that oh I think you can't
do away with the family with the family
identity
I know of no family in the world whether
it be South America here Europe that is
not extremely complex but you can't do
away with the family entity you just
cannot do that but you have to learn to
live with it and learn to learn to live
with the weaknesses and the strengths
and to grow from that you know and I
think this was a tremendously smart
script the writing here was brilliant
and we had a wonderful team working with
the Downey's in wealth with David and
you know it was just very unique in each
day you came in he you didn't have a
chance to talk or think about it a lot
you just dive in and do it you just have
to do it you know it's like once again
is from it's from from you know the
journey from ink to behavior you try to
find behavior within within a an
imaginary set of circumstances with each
take and with each day's work you know
and that's what it boils down to talk
and listen listen and talk as we're
doing now if you do that purely and
don't cheat it then I think you'll be
rewarded around the corner with
something more complex and more
emotional who if called for and that
will be more truthful if you stay
truthful on a simple level the thing
that's been the most rewarding is you
know sometimes I'll get off the phone
with the publicity person who's just
seeing it and they'll be like at the end
of the call be like hey wait a minute I
just wanted to tell you that you know I
lost my father I have this complex issue
with my brother I mean I can't believe
how many people keep coming out of the
woodwork and it's just a really
beautiful and rewarding experience to
see you know I've known a lot about
laughter and people disappearing for two
hours in that it's another thing to see
people kind of have their lives I mean
that's the whole point of movies I mean
I really do believe in we used to sit
around a camp
fire and tell stories and we would have
a cathartic experience and we understood
life better and we were somehow less
alone because we shared those stories
and I believe in the lights going out
and that campfire is on the screen and
we share the story again and that's why
I think it's important that drama stays
in a movie theater you know it's great
what's happening on television but I
yearn for those things you know I
understood the divorce of my friends
because I saw Kramer vs Kramer and I saw
people work through that and I
understood it was okay to go to therapy
because I saw ordinary people with my
parents uncomfortably next to me but I
you know and had already been in and out
once but it was one of those things
where like I really do believe in this
art form be for those reasons and it's
really cool to think that somewhere in
some way we kind of fit into the lineage
of that storytelling